so welcome back to the iced coffee hour
you got uh graham
got jack we got a very special guest for
you
who is uh sitting in the other room
right now we're doing some social
distancing
this is one i'm really excited about
doing oh yeah yeah
and we're going to be talking about
everything from business ventures we're
going to be talking about investing
uh we're going to be talking about some
very intense
uh debates topics business uh we got a
book here philosophy and uh with that
said we're
gonna announce our guest right over here
also
we've made approximately i think like
sixteen hundred sorry i don't have the
exact number i know you guys wanna hear
it but i usually just reserve that
statistic for when graham and i are
together but we have a guest you guys
wanted it it's like sixteen hundred
dollars
go that's how much we've made so far for
the podcast so
welcome dax flame to the 11th ever
episode of the iced coffee hour how are
you doing
i'm doing good how are y'all doing super
well
really excited to uh to meet you and
have you on yeah this was actually
something i was i was so looking forward
to this
i'm actually i might actually have to
move my uh my mic over here because
we're gonna do more talking
this is something i was really looking
forward to me too uh and by the way guys
if you're wondering why we're in
different rooms we're social distancing
right now we're being responsible
so so welcome and uh just to give you
uh you all a little introduction on who
dax is
he's an og youtuber so at one point he
was the 16th
most subscribed channel on youtube and
uh
around what year was that dax 2007 2007.
so i mean i was nine that's crazy
nine at that time so but graham you're
the same age as me 28.
30. okay yeah just turned 30.
um by the way quick off topic tangent
here i posted
my first youtube video in 2000 i think
six or seven
believe it or not there's a youtube
video of me playing the drums in 2007.
really really huh yeah i'm sure i can
find it
so what first made you want to make a
youtube video
dax just to express myself and share
some of my feelings with people and kind
of just seeing that this thing called
video blogging existed and wanting to
like
do some of that myself keep a video
diary entry
um um yeah that was yeah that was 2007
as well so similar timeline
15 years old you're 15. i guess you were
17 yeah
what was that like to have a few of your
videos just take off i mean i i know
some of those early videos for you
like for a million views on a plat like
a brand new platform nobody had seen
that before
yeah it was very very interesting and
very very
cool uh and it just felt like a whole
swarm of people
in a way it felt like the whole world
was watching but at the same time i knew
it wasn't really
but it felt that way sort of to an
extent because at that point you haven't
yet seen the world when you're that
young
and so it feels very big and
just a wild experience did you did you
get recognized back then
not while i was making videos not till
after i quit making videos because then
i quit
uh i quit making videos around 17 or
like 16 or something and uh and
then i acted in movies shortly after i
graduated high school at 18 i acted in
project decks
and that movie got uh that movie was uh
so then i got recognized from that but
mostly from 21 jump street which i acted
in
the following year um so i acted in 21
jump street the following year
they both were released in 2012. so
after they were released i went and
traveled lots
and i wrote a book and then i moved to
la
and um yeah yeah
why did you stop making youtube videos
when you were coming near like the peak
of your youtube success
because uh i had
i just didn't want to make them anymore
um yeah i just didn't feel like making
videos anymore
was there something that happened or was
there something with it that sparked it
where one day you woke up it's like you
know what
it's not into it today was it was there
something that led up to that or was you
just tired of it
i don't really remember uh also today my
memory is really foggy
because i was telling you i didn't sleep
really well yeah so
i am not as sharply focused as i usually
am you're okay
so i can only imagine being at the top
of youtube at the time obviously youtube
wasn't as prolific as it is now
but were you like the cool kid on campus
since you had you know like a hundred
thousand subscribers
no because no one cared about youtube
back then
huh have you considered starting a tick
tock
someone told me to maybe i would to i
don't know
i don't know i don't have any tick tock
ideas but maybe she seems like a good
like a vital part of being an influencer
they say
who knows i would do it i get i gave in
i thought it was i thought it was stupid
i said i seriously thought like what's
the point of this and then
i started seeing everybody come up on
him like wait it's like maybe maybe
there's something
i said the same thing about instagram
though i thought it was the stupidest
thing and then
i realized like you have to do it so how
about this
uh if you create uh a tick tock
by the time this post on sunday i'll
link it in the description
okay but if it's not in the description
that means you've decided not to do it
that's a good idea
okay i
all right i have other things that i
would be interested in talking about
that i think could be linked to in the
description
but i can run them by you and see what
you think yes
so i think i think everyone has a pretty
good understanding of who you were you
were featured in
a couple mainstream films and uh you
know your youtube fame
how how was it
acting in in project x and 22 jump
street how was that
that changed from being on youtube to
all of a sudden like
being catered to and uh like being in
mainstream film
really fun to be in hollywood movies
it's so fun
um um um
yeah it's such a good experience
did people because i know you don't work
at the ice cream shop anymore
oh yeah so should i explain that yes yes
okay maybe we could give a little bit of
background on the ice cream man
oh sure yes yeah people may not know
this a famous content creator idubbbz
made like a documentary about dax and
oh about i'm so curious about that you
want me to summarize that yeah yes
really quick though how did that happen
because i
love his content and i love the
documentary style and when i saw that
come up
i was like oh well i know what i'm doing
tonight cool so
uh so yeah macy and i watched it and we
were immediately like did you know who i
i was before that no oh cool uh-uh
interesting so that was really cool
and they were like wait a second it was
amazing ideas like we should reach out
and you got back to me immediately yeah
and so we're watching it
as you're getting back to me it's like
the craziest thing i was so excited
yeah i've heard about you through um
youtube yeah and uh see your thumbnails
pop up a lot like i react to
how they spend money yes um so so that's
interesting to me too because i am not
good with money but i've trying been
trying to educate myself more
um and so that's what excited me so much
too
um so i uh
got famous on youtube i acted in those
movies
traveled around wrote some books moved
to la
all my opportunities dried up so i
needed to find a way to make money
tried to create an invention that
invention did not pan out
had to find another job started driving
lyft and a food delivery job
got a job at an ice cream shop that ice
cream shop job lasted about
15 months about 12 months into it
i i ran into idubbbz
uh ian and he
uh was really nice nice when i when i
met him
a really nice person and he
uh had asked me if i wanted to meet up
for lunch to discuss a documentary idea
and so he just said yeah i would like to
do that and i'd watch this full force
one and i thought it was really good
so then we decided to do it and then a
month or so later
we started to record it and then
uh i was just with them for a week and
uh and then i would just keep in touch
via text
and then it came out recently so it's
been really exciting about a week ago it
came out
um so that's how it came to fruition and
how it all happened
what an exciting time it's been um so
lucky uh yeah really
good time really great experience how do
you run into ian how did that happen
uh i went to a party at jack's films
house
uh because i know jack from
youtube um yeah that's crazy though that
you just coincidentally
met idubbbz and he knew of you and you
know of him
and what was it like meeting him is he
is he like he is on on camera because
i'm actually i'm a huge idubbbz fan as
well
yeah i think i'd met him before well i
know i'd met him before too but i hadn't
talked to him a whole lot but i talked
to him there and he was just so nice
um um yeah he's just nice and really
nice person
and uh like uh whenever you're at a
party and you don't know a lot of people
it's nice to have someone you can talk
to first
for a bit and so that was that was very
nice running into him and
good presence that's the thing i like
about youtube is because
everybody watches each other you can
meet a brand new person who you never
know before but it's like you're
instantly friends because you've seen
them for so much like i've met some of
my best friends through youtube
we've like we've maybe watched each
other on youtube for like a year or two
years and then you meet and you're like
instant friends because you know about
each other all right like you already
know you're gonna get along
yeah so it's it's fantastic for meeting
people and i had not seen a whole lot of
things but i i just whenever i had met
him
i thought he was so nice i just looked
him up again that night and watched a
few of his videos and watched the full
force one
and i was like oh wow i really like this
i loved the full forest one yeah soft
fatty is like such a nice
seeming interesting person he is
oh absolutely well that's exciting and
and his video is untrending
yeah i think it was number two trending
it didn't make it to number one though
for two so when you met him at the party
is that when he came up with the idea to
have the ice cream man it wasn't
something that he had
thought of before but it was when he met
you learned that you were working at an
ice cream shop at the time
and then decided to make a documentary i
don't know i can't remember if we
discussed working at an ice cream shop
till we had lunch and discuss the
documentary or at the party
i don't remember um yeah i don't
remember
about how long ago was this october
uh mid october of 2019.
so no 2000 yet 2019.
so you filmed the documentary like a
long time ago and it took him
like seven months to get it all ready to
go and edit
yeah yeah yeah wow a man
named dane uh was really talented editor
who edited the whole
thing and then ian edited parts of it
too i think i'm not exactly sure but
they work together with someone named
ben and they're all really good
yeah i can't imagine the amount of
filming and work that goes on behind
that and planning
yeah it's just insane to put that
together
it's like it doesn't surprise me that it
would take
many months to craft something like that
to release it
did you make a documentary before the
the closest one i made
two that were semi one was with this guy
ben mala
and i flew to florida to learn about a
story i spent the entire day filming
with him and then i spent about 18 maybe
20 hours straight
editing the entire video together and
then uh pokemane
did a video with her and i tried to make
it more documentary style i did my best
it's tough i mean that was a solid i
don't know 15 12 hours
of editing just editing that went into
that not to mention all the planning and
the filming and the background work and
the coordinate i mean there's so much
that went into
to making like a 20 minute video yeah i
enjoyed it was fun it was a good
creative challenge
something i want to do more of yeah it
is fun
yeah like i look at that like like ian's
video is inspiration for me
yeah that's cool seeing how that was
just constructed to me was like
wow like that's what that's what i would
love to do one day like something
similar to that well that's exciting
that's really finance version of that
the money version yeah
there's you could probably find it you
you could probably find a money youtuber
to make that documentary about
mm-hmm yeah oh yeah the possibilities
are limitless so if anyone's watching
do you call yourself a money youtuber or
like a finance youtuber
it's it's so hard i i hate saying i
usually go with
finance but most people think finance is
really boring so it's like what do you
make of any other oh
in that i just say kind of like i make
video investing on youtube but i try to
steer away usually i'm in real estate
that's that's usually the go to is
real estate okay cool so to save saves a
whole bunch because nobody gets it
otherwise
yeah yeah did people recognize you uh
when you were working at the ice cream
shop often yeah
a lot of people recognized me at the ice
cream shop
what do you think you were recognized
mostly for 21 jump street
yeah that's that's how i knew of you it
was 21 jump street and then the jubilee
video that you were in as well but
we'll cover that in a little bit oh
maybe we should just talk about it now
you want to guess what we all have in
common all three of us
jubilee videos and laugh yep
well i've never had a chatting with but
i've been in a jubilee video yes
oh what jubilee video were you in um
people are going to find it yeah you can
you could bleep but how about this you
bleep it out
okay it's also me and you were both on
pewdiepie
yes oh wow that's true wow i mean that's
a flex
that is a huge flag okay that's that's
yeah yeah i was
oh okay and then what you were mine was
uh millionaire versus minimum wage
marker
oh i saw that yeah i don't remember it
that much
but i have definitely seen that yeah oh
and then do all millionaires think the
same
or maybe i saw that one yeah that was
the more recent one but the first one
was a bigger video
so exciting stuff yeah cool
so um in that in the jubilee video you
were in essentially the premise is
you have two different teams each team
is uh comprised of three people
and they have to try to either like
choose blue or choose red
and if both teams choose blue then they
get to split a pot of money
if one chooses blue one chooses red the
red team gets to take the entire pot of
money if
both teams choose red both teams get
nothing
you were the only person out of all six
people that were in it that wanted to
share the money
oh yeah everyone else wanted to to steal
it yeah
share it i mean that's what i i'd be in
the same position i'd just be like guys
let's
it's guaranteed let's just share it
right you walk away a winner
tru true that's that's a good point it's
um it's
yeah it is a big
uh conundrum the prisoner's dilemma yep
when idubbbz and you filmed ice cream
man did he have an outline already
prepared
or was it a rough outline or did you
guys kind of just
go with the flow when you're filming it
we didn't have any specific plan
for the documentary he just wanted to i
think
film a week with me and see where it
went and
i think he knew that he wanted to help
me create something and so whenever he
was thinking about the game show or
something i think this is how it went i
think he was just like oh yeah i love
this idea and that we'd like to help you
make it
so that was really a very lucky
set of circumstances for me to get to
create something
uh just have someone fund it for me and
everything and help me produce it
uh so so that was amazing and now
my goal is to make more smoothie madness
i want to sell it to a network
and create a full series
a full season and uh
i also might in the meantime since i
don't know how long that would take
i might like to self-produce a few
episodes but i'm very nervous
about can i say we say the illness
i'm very nervous about the virus and so
i might have to find out a way to do a
socially distanced version of it
so can you give a little outline of what
smoothie madness is
so yeah is the sunlighting okay yep yeah
um
smoothie madness is a game show i made
uh with
ian and dane and ben uh in will
osmond's kitchen uh it's a it's a game
show about
like making smoothies it's just a health
themed game show
um and it went really well like i was
very
awkward for a first time host so i have
to
like work on that and try and figure out
how to be more um charismatic
and so yeah it was it was a hit though
everyone loved it so
that's really exciting it was fun to
watch yes it was
different it's fun and entertaining yeah
i like by the way how it what how it how
it seemed to be a bit unplanned
yeah there's some structure but but
there are a lot of things that you're
just like
what do we do okay you kind of make it
up a little bit as you go depending on
the story like i liked that because i
think people can relate to something raw
yes that's what i liked about it but my
question is
we're going to talk a little money here
why sell it
because this is something easy enough
that you would be able to do on your own
you could keep a hundred percent of the
revenue you don't have to share it with
anybody
this is easy enough where you just do
you make a smoothie madness youtube
channel
and then as you grow it you start
getting sponsors to that
then imagine you start getting like uh
what is it g-fuel
all of a sudden you you g fuel pays you
like 30 grand
to to figure out a smoothie with g-fuel
in it and a million people watch that
video now it's sponsored by g-fuel and
you could do that with like other
products and
blenders you know there's a lot of
things that you could do with that
and each episode i bet could be filmed
for
i don't know under a thousand bucks if
you're willing to put in a lot of the
work behind the scenes it's really just
the equipment
getting people on having them sign a
release the ingredients i'd say about a
thousand dollars
but hire two people for the day to help
you out a thousand bucks
that's a good point and something i
should maybe ask you more about
which could lead me into asking you
about
in business the most important
thing is to know why you're doing it
right
you you need to know what your motive is
if it's business it does it's does it
make money i mean really
that's that's it is it a viable way to
make money but if you get into a new
venture
you need to ask yourself why am i doing
this why do i want this money
so you just answered the question of
do why do i want money fund
my game show because you just said it
would cost a thousand dollars per
episode
threw that number on i bet you could do
it for less oh yeah
that's perfect yeah so if i can make
enough money to start
paying a thousand dollars or say 500 per
episode
i could make it on my own so how do i
make money
let's let's let's go back a little let's
figure out how much realistically this
would cost you
realistically i bet you you could do it
do you have a camera
no i have an iphone 6 but i'm probably
just gonna success okay so but i'm
probably gonna buy a better camera soon
so here's the equipment you would need
you would need two lava maybe three
lavalier microphones three lavaliers so
i would say six hundred dollars
for that you dean maybe two to three
cameras okay so let's say you buy them
used six hundred dollars a camera that's
eighteen hundred dollars
tripods lighting or maybe at three
thousand dollars three thousand dollar
investment
um let's let's even round it up to 3 500
because we're going to add blenders into
the mix
i'd say 3 500 blenders you have you have
the blender so just three thousand
three thousand bucks uh that's really
what i think it would take is three
thousand dollars you need a space to
film in
that's what you start off with then you
need the ingredients and uh and then
people to run the cameras
uh and maybe an editor yes which
maybe so three thousand down payment
three thousand
down per episode maybe add in a 500
yeah 500 so so the ingredients let's
just say a hundred bucks 120
for ingredients you'd have to pay people
to get on which i'm sure at this point
people are willing to do it for free but
since
you have to pay them but okay but since
you don't well you don't want
subscribers like fans going on and doing
you want it to be like
real honest like people yeah i want them
to have a reward okay
so another few hundred bucks to pay them
i think you could do a lot of the
filming yourself if you don't mind just
running around they're turning on the
cameras doing it yourself maybe one
person to help you out
pay that person 100 bucks for the day
you could edit yourself
if you want to uh so you could
technically do this for maybe four or
500 bucks an episode
okay if you do a lot of the work
yourself i don't think you would be
profitable in the beginning unless you
get a sponsor up front
so you could what i would probably do is
do one episode
and use that almost like a proof of
concept so you would have to come up
with the money up front
yeah i know you already had the episode
do one more okay
because right now you gotta want to do
one more yeah you've got to do one more
episode because
right now any sponsor i think would look
at that one video and be like okay well
obviously it has a lot of views but
that's because of of idubbbz video
everyone's coming and of course they're
like what can you do on your own
independent from him so they're going to
want to see that if you could show that
you're getting 50 or 60 000 views
it would be a lot easier for you to go
to a business
or ask for some sort of sponsorship or
something
that would at least pay your overhead in
the beginning that's
a good idea you do it for free thank you
yeah and of course so you do the first
ones for free and then as you start
building up momentum you get ad revenue
you can maybe look into some affiliates
of some sort blenders
yeah you could you could affiliate
market blenders you maybe get a few
bucks per one that you sold i think they
would be every anyone watching it would
probably want to support you at this
point
maybe a patreon for some behind the
scenes look into this i think would be
ten dollars a month fifteen dollars a
month and they get access to all the
behind the scenes footage
because you're going to have a condensed
down version but what about behind the
scenes is they're kind of figuring out
what to do you're gonna have a lot of
footage what to do with that
sell it so i think in the beginning
you're not gonna make much money
at the best case scenario break even but
i think over a few months
if you if you do like an episode a week
i think there's money to be made in that
excellent advice thank you
you're welcome and then you could always
expand from there and
i think you can go crazier by like
upping the ante
like as you start making more money
reinvest it back into the channel be
like okay today guys
we're giving away like a 1998 honda
civic
like it's like something just something
you give people like a crazy
prize you you change up you could change
up the rules
in every single episode so no episode's
the same like today we got a special
episode where you could put
like you know you could you could se i
know you said the sabotage thing but
they could they could put an ingredient
in there and then you have someone
blindfolded in the back taste testing or
something crazy that's yeah i agree a
lot of ways you can go with that
totally that might be my first step
right now is
uh what is your
uh coaster oh
twenty dollar bill oh wow it's uh
is that normal or just for the podcast
that's just just for the podcast these
are i bought them on amazon
it's fake oh okay yeah so it has some uh
some
some i believe they're chinese symbols
on the side so you can't like but they
it's just a funny little thing i bought
them for thumbnails and then now we use
them as coasters
i was like wow okay
yeah but that's my thought don't sell it
cool it's better it's better you do it
on your own especially now
people can do everything pretty much on
their own they don't need to sell
anybody
they don't need to to get picked up by a
network you are now your own network
i think there's a lot of excitement
around smoothie madness right now
yeah obviously you can't really film it
due to corn
i i had an idea to just film trivia
version
how would you do that well round three
is just trivia like like
there wouldn't be the most essential
ingredient which is the blending
and making a smoothie but people would
like it as a holdover
and that's the benefit of selling to a
network
is they might know how to build a studio
big enough to where you can do it
socially distanced
i don't think there's any rush to it
like imagine um everyone's saying adult
swim or imagine the food network or
um yeah you know what i would do if
you're worried about everything is just
make smoothies yourself
what make them yourself just just do
they pick the ingredients and i blend
them
yes is is so two things one if you want
to involve your
your audience you get them to make a
suggestion of what you make a smoothie
of
it could be anything people could say
like put salmon in the smoothie like
like what just any ingredients that
people upvote in the comments
like just say this whatever people
comment
i'm gonna pick the top five things in a
week
and i'm gonna make a smoothie out of it
and i'm gonna drink it you know within
reason
of course but i need to have contestants
no no but this
this would just be you in the beginning
you would you would
get the top ingredients from people
whatever they suggest you would film
yourself
going to the store buying the
ingredients having it all laid out
and then you have a blender you put it
in the blender and then you
you do it yourself and you rate it um
kind of like report of the week
except you would make your own smoothie
and that might help build some momentum
at least you build an audience around
what you what you like that's a good
idea
i i like both of these thank you thank
you that is a great idea i hadn't
thought of
either of those do honestly right now do
as much as you can on your own in the
very beginning
grow it now like even tonight you get
back i would start posting on videos
on if you watch hot ones what's up hot
ones yes
that's a good show that would be a good
thing for me to follow
yes exactly i would do something like
that but in the beginning i would just
do you
you don't have to worry about meeting
any new people you could film on your
own time your own schedule
right now i think you got so much
momentum i think it's really important
just to carry that momentum
yeah because what i've noticed this time
is like you have this small little
window
that opens up every now and then and if
you don't jump through that window it
closes up
and then you gotta find another window
so you i think you got the window open
it only comes every
five or so years i don't i don't know
how often windows happen
maybe it's what it's probably about
right
yeah like every five or so years
sometimes longer sometimes less
sometimes not at all yep i would say
that that's been about true maybe every
five years or so some opportunities come
up that's like yeah
take it so i think now you got a window
and i think it's just worth it you just
gotta like double down right now
yes make the smoothie con or just
anything but i would do the smoothie
content on your channel
post like every other day every three
days you'll build so much more momentum
than if you don't do anything for a
month and then you come back into it
okay you could find the people on
craigslist too yeah that would be a good
way to find some random people
that's how we did it that's how we did
it what would be even funnier is
go and model mayhem get some like
professional models
seriously that would be amazing
that would be something i'd just like it
to be a
i guess that would be a different theme
i mean i could
do different themed episodes like model
smoothie madness
that would be a million view video i kid
you not maybe for one of them but i
would like it to be open to everyone
yes yeah no maybe yeah no i agree but
like splitting it up
like one episode yeah that's that's
smart that you'd have like a dynamic
theme like
constantly changing the rules changing
you know the
type of contestant that you have i was
thinking maybe have brett come back
and host the second episode and i can
kind of learn from him a little bit
maybe leticia moves on to the second
round
uh winner winner moves on winner moves
on
loser hosts co-hosts i i still think
that you you should you're a good host
yeah no co-host oh okay on the topic
back on the topic of ice cream man were
you nervous
for this video yeah sure i was nervous
filming
uh uh but i get nervous
all the time so i don't mind being
nervous you just you just move right
through it
and then for it coming out i wasn't
nervous i was just busy
uh because i wrote this new book and i
wanted to get it finished
uh and i'm gonna release it it's live
actually now but i haven't announced it
it's on amazon so i'm going to announce
that i brought a copy to bring to you
thank you tell us about the book what is
the book
um you'll like the title it's
dax flame's guide to making money as an
influencer ooh
and it's autographed thank you can i can
i grab it
yeah okay hold on do you like that title
i do
let's see here we go
i'm gonna keep this wow look at it it
says
you get the little tape so it's official
not for resale oh i mean that's because
it's a proof copy so
so the the official copies won't have
that so you have one of a kind the only
other person who has that is me i have
two i printed two proof copies
first two copies in existence so you
have one of them so you should save that
it's worth a lot of money maybe someday
maybe someday maybe
if people like it that's awesome
so tell us about the book what is the
book about it's also this little drawing
i brought
if you want it it says ice cream man yes
oh you don't
all have to frame that that's cool a man
hired me to draw him a tattoo and that
was the design he didn't want to use
and uh and then i added to it a little
wait a second wait this is even more
wait wait so you designed someone's
tattoo
yeah someone messaged me on instagram so
i drew their tattoo
how did when when did that happen a
couple days after
uh everything came out did he send you a
picture of the tattoo
he hasn't gotten it yet oh okay when is
he gonna get it because if we could put
if we could put a screenshot here
if you're telling me i'll message him
and see oh yeah how about this if you
message him and say
if he gets a tattoo and sends a picture
we'll put it we'll put it on here
if he gets it before saturday morning
yeah
i'll i will message him saturday morning
you can turn up okay
if anyone ever wants a tattoo of the
iced coffee hour or graham we'll put it
on here we'll feature it i don't know if
that's a isn't that a lot of pressure
that like what you drew is gonna be on
someone's
body forever no because he he wanted he
said just do whatever
i would i would feel and like some
people take tattoos very lightly
yeah yeah i look at that and like that's
a permanent decision
that's that's on like i'm going to have
to be 80 years old and and look at that
he's been mowing me 100 bucks what's up
you've been mowed me 100 bucks
well for 100 that changes everything uh
and he took the one that was the least
effort like i just drew a dog and he
liked that best
you know what that's a story though yeah
that's a story when you're out with your
buddies
you say hey look at look at this guess
what
it's a story behind it that's true wow
that's incredible but tell us about the
book
the book is called dax flames guide to
making money as an influencer okay
uh how much much of your audience wants
to make money make money as an
influencer i would say honestly i would
say about five percent of my audience
would want to be
an influencer and make money i'd say the
other 95 care about personal finance but
say five percent okay maybe this could
be a good book for
just about all of them i guess like
because the other person people care
about
finance yeah yeah it's about it's about
starting a business
the book is about attempting to start a
business yeah um
did you check out either the websites i
sent you you did oh awesome
uh is it okay if i go into my questions
at all of course
let's let's let's do it we got we got
other questions and we'll
so we'll save them but let's let's hear
what you have to say so
the motive behind
starting a business is the key
to keeping motivated um um
if you don't know why you're doing what
you're doing why you want money
you'll just give up so i know
that i want to create more smoothie
madness i know i want to write fun
my screenplays and so having this in
mind
i can approach these different i know i
don't want to work an ice cream shop
so having that in mind i can approach
these different business opportunities
and see if i can uh make something out
of them
it's it's sometimes it's it seems out of
your depth but you can't doubt yourself
so you just go for it right
so um i sent graham these two
websites i created wealthyinfluencer.com
great domain name yeah and then
friendboom.com good domain decent
okay uh but wealthy influencer is great
i prefer wealthy influencers yeah that's
a great versus
friend boom um friend boom is good once
you learn what the site is about i think
you know i will get your opinion on it
because i don't know which one do you
want to start with
so let's start with friend boom
okay no let's start with wealthy
influencer because that's what the book
is about okay
the book is about early quarantine
and starting a business in early
quarantine
all of a sudden i've got no money
but i've got unemployment checks coming
so
all of a sudden i have all this free
time and i'm just in my apartment with
all this time in my hands
which in a way is a dream come true
obviously the circumstances of the world
were not good but
in that way it was good for me
in that i got the unemployment and so i
created this website
and it was a like something i just threw
myself into
wanted to see if i could start this
business you know teach people how to
make money as an influencer
and there's a whole drama element to it
that i wrote in the book
uh and and honestly i don't know if it
will work out or not like
at this point once the documentary
started coming out i gave up on the
website
and started moving on to other things
but now that i'm here with you
i think it's a good time to revisit it
and um
so wealthyinfluencer.com
you go there to learn how to make money
as an influencer
um it has courses
it has a tool section and it's not
developed yet but
originally i was trying to see if i
could just sell it i wanted to see if i
could sell it
to someone so i made a video website for
sale
anyone interested in buying it the
feedback i mainly got was similar to the
feedback i got when i was trying to sell
my invention ip
which you can't sell a concept
i would agree with that so
friendboom.com
is where i'm going to try and do things
right
also but you can sell a good domain name
yes
so that is a great once in a lifetime
domain name
you think i would say it's a i would say
it's a very it's a good
domain name how much is it worth would
you say it's tough to sell domain names
i gotta say because people are placing
less emphasis
on a good domain name and instead on
like an app
or something with an audience already
attached to it
fewer and fewer people are going to what
about a domain name that's written about
in a book
which book that book this book
it depends how many visitors you have i
mean it's it's difficult to sell a
concept and it's very difficult to sell
a domain name
unless you're selling a domain name that
gets a lot of traffic
or something that is associated with a
brand like what was it
nissan.com do you see that the guy the
guy
the guy owns nissan.com and i think
nissan the the car manufacturer offered
to buy
what's up cease and desist they sent him
that but he he had
i think in like the 80s or 70s uh i
think it was it was some sort of
product or something that was that was
nissan or was like his last name or
something i forget what it was but he
had the rights to that wow
so they they try to get a seasoned
assist the judge ruled that he has the
right to own nissan.com
and um then they got in a big legal
battle
between the two and then this guy let's
see if it's still let's see if it's all
up it's very interesting
if you go to nissan.com he uh let's see
nissan.com let's see if it's still up
there
it's like this really jinky looking
website
i really hope it's up here because it's
a very interesting story but they
offered him like 20 million dollars to
this website
and he said no he turned it down so he
sold he didn't sell it
i don't believe so oh yeah this is it
jack you could put this on the thing it
says nissan motors lawsuit against us it
can happen to you or someone else
nissan.com that was the website up until
maybe just recently
wow so anyway
so yeah so now you see it's nissan usa
calm as your website so that's a good
point so you need so
wealthy influencer won't be worth
anything until it's developed correct
i think realistically your time is best
spent
developing and developing um smoothie
madness that's what i believe too i
think you should really
focus on smoothie madness especially
considering the fact that
you have all of this this outreach
specifically from the
the ice cream man video specifically
wanting more smoothie madness i mean i
agree completely i just kind of thought
and this was
back when before smoothie madness was
like i knew if it was going to happen or
not that i created this website
so now that it's like i have smoothie
madness i'll probably just shift my
focus to that
but since i was coming on here i thought
it was the perfect time to kind of get
some kind of either finality about it
or closure or to get
some invigoration yeah so it seems more
the closure route
but it does lead me into friend boom can
i tell you about that yes
friendboom.com is a really good idea
that i wish
existed and more so as an app friend
boom the app
which name could be changed if you don't
think that's a great domain name
um but i was even thinking of
like selling that it'd be better to
develop it
first but i want to focus my energy on
smoothie madness
so this is a crazy idea that i don't
know if it's good you can tell me
i was even gonna just like list it on
ebay
and try and sell friendboom.com now i
know what you're thinking
that's a concept and a domain name but
i would agree to stay like with it
or be the face of the company for many
years so you would be getting
friendboom.com and a guarantee that i
would make one video about it
once it's done so what is friend boom
think of tinder but you do it with a
personality test so you take a
personality test
and it tells you and then the other
person takes the personality test
and then if it combines people it
matches people
with who is most compatible um
additionally
also ask you about your availability
each week so each week you would tell
them what your availability is
also sorry if this is not a good idea
but i'm just pitching it sort of
so each week it tells you you say oh i'm
free monday wednesday friday i want to
hang out with someone
and uh and then it matches you with
someone who's compatible and free at the
same times
uh you also say what kind of activities
you're open to and it matches you like
that
so it's like more of a sophisticated
like sort of matching up than like
um meetup.com or something so it's a
good way for people to meet each other
which will be really valuable in the
post
future when you know people are kind of
separated and it's something i wish
existed because i love meeting people so
much
additionally if you are someone who
doesn't love meeting people because you
don't know what to say and stuff
there will be certain uh tools and games
on
on the app where you set the phone in
the middle of the table you say i want
to do the conversation facilitator
and like it'll it'll like suggest
different topics to talk about every
five minutes
so it's like never an awkward moment
well maybe you can't guarantee that but
never a silent moment
um and then um maybe like random little
games you can do
so it just kind of facilitates
friendship uh and
so it could be pretty cool like like if
you move to a new city
uh it'd be perfect for that um
so that is my like idea of it do you
think that would be good to sell
on an auction how much how much would
you sell it for
i'd probably set the reserve what do you
think what do you think
i would take 5 000 okay
but if i did it as an auction it might
go even higher
would you invest in it here's the thing
here's here's my thought of it
um you making one video about it that's
really what you got to see that as is
is that's you sponsoring something so
whoever buys that let's just they're
getting a brand deal
they would want you to just make a video
promoting something so it depends how
many eyeballs you can get on that
um i i think the idea is actually
interesting i really do
i think i think it's it's it's fun um
my only thoughts are developing an
algorithm like that and making an
app that's actually functional is
insanely expensive
so it's not something that people can
just do in their spare time for like a
thousand bucks
maybe if they're really good at coding
but it'd be worth it right potentially
then you get into the issue of
uh first of all i don't know what the
liability is if you get two people
together and all of a sudden now
someone steals something you invite them
into your house and all of a sudden now
the watches are gone or the artwork is
gone cinder can do it why
couldn't anything anyone else you would
have to look into that
okay just just a thought of it yeah yeah
because when you match
people based on an algorithm
thought is with with some of these
dating apps is maybe a little bit more
random they just they throw everything
together
and it's up to you to say yes or no
should i throw myself
into this and like just be like okay
there are these things that
uh that are definitely going to be
challenges and so hard to overcome
like should i throw myself into that or
should i
what i'm leaning towards throw myself
into my main passion
creativity and think we'll see like if i
threw myself into the other thing
i could get rich and then i could use
that money
to fund my creativity here's the thing
is i i think
i i think the friend boom idea is
interesting i think it's gonna
cost a lot of money to set it up it's
gonna cost a lot of money to run it
it's gonna be very time intensive to
make that successful
it's a fun idea i think it could be
something where people would be like
okay let's let's make a youtube video
today let's let's go on friend boom and
to see
we link up with and film it it it's
interesting in that sense
but if you're doing that to just so you
could do your passion
better to do your passion i think
smoothie madness you could just you
could do way more
it would be way easier for you just make
smoothies
and not think about anything else just
make smoothies here's the problem though
i love making smoothie madness but i'm
worried about corona
you did suggest some very good
alternatives and i need to think of that
more so maybe i shouldn't suggest any
problems i should just
process this just solutions no problems
only solutions
okay i would if i were you if i were you
the only thing i would do right now is
tonight i would plan
out uh no actually here's what i would
do if i were you
tomorrow i want you to i i sound i sound
demanding i want you to do this if it
were me if i were you
tomorrow i would make a video i'd plan
it out tonight i'd post it tomorrow
i'd say something like hey guys i'm
going to be making smoothie madness
just me this episode what i'm going to
do is i'm going to take
the top five ingredients that you
comment down below and that you like to
the top
after like two days i'm going to go and
buy those ingredients i'm going to make
a smoothie out of it
and i'll let you know how it tastes no
matter what it is
as long as it's not poisonous to me i'll
i'll blend it whether it's it's steak
bananas choc whatever the top five are
you do it
it's gonna get people really engaged in
that video and anyone who comments
especially if they're comments
they're gonna be so excited that you go
and make a video like this that is a
great idea
can i do it not tomorrow because i want
to put out the book tomorrow
whenever you're ready because i don't
want to put two videos out on the same
day right fair
you want to use the momentum that you
have from idubbbz though
yes i mean my only thought is the sooner
you jump on it
the easier it's going to become to just
to get that push
you know that that's what i've always
been like it's just
i'm always on it like as soon as i see
something it's just you gotta get it
done gotta get it done and it's just
very like antsy
so i feel like the sooner you start the
more momentum that's gonna build up over
time
okay it's my only thought as far as the
the friend boom thing
i actually thought it was a really good
idea and when i when i saw your web page
i like i lit up because i thought it was
such a cool idea such a cool concept
i would be open anyone who wants to take
that idea
you can take it and make it because i
would like to use it
but also maybe i'm going to make an
auction
guaranteeing a
brand deal or whatever yes i think if
you don't mind making videos on it or
promoting it then i think maybe it's
sellable because people could say
okay you're going to get x amount of
views per video a certain amount of
people are going to
get a website that's already been talked
about on graham's podcast
exactly so and he's all about we're
making
the value go up
and then and then dax is going to be on
the other side on ebay just bidding it
up
oh no i wouldn't do that that's illegal
oh i know i guess right
what's up that's illegal yes if they
catch you it has to catch you
oh that's true but i would i wouldn't do
that i believe you
um another thing okay this was something
that ian suggested i talk about
and i thought it was great advice now i
have
about 10 or twelve thousand dollars
saved
um but i have more coming in
through that's money that i've saved
because the unemployment checks have
been a lot more than
the restaurant i was working at so i
have that saved up which is awesome
but i have even more coming in through
book sales
also t-shirt sales i don't know the
numbers but i think that should be a lot
so i might come to a point where i have
thirty thousand dollars maybe more
what should i do with that money how
much do you spend every month
like two thousand dollars a month like
how does that break down how much is
your rent
and sixty 1366 dollars that's good for
la
that's good and what about like car
payment insurance gas
i think that i i think everything comes
out to like 1600 or 1650 and then i just
pay for food and gas
or 16 yeah okay so necessity so two
thousand dollars a month i don't buy
anything i don't go anywhere right now
i'm just in quarantine so yeah
like that's pretty much the minimum two
thousand dollars a month
yeah what about before i could live for
if i do get up to 30 000 bucks
i could live a full year without working
i could find a job way better than
the sushi restaurant i was at because i
worked at sushi for a bit after ice
cream
and uh that would be awesome to not work
that long
plus in that time i could develop
smoothie madness
or any other ideas so it's a really
lucky fortunate thing and also thank you
to everyone who is an essential worker
and everyone watching uh
good luck and then yes so
so before quarantine about the same i
don't really spend a lot
a lot of money on stuff what do you
think
okay well just like max out or off ira
ah yeah yes and no okay so
what's your income going to be like when
unemployment goes down
i'll have no income but i will have
hopefully these book sales in addition
to the book sales i'm already making
and hopefully i can do something with
smoothie maps okay so my advice would be
because your income is inconsistent
right now
and you don't know if it's gonna be zero
dollars a month or five
thousand dollars a month or four that we
don't really know quite yet
what i would honestly do is i would
probably caution you against
investing that money right now i think
that's that's your safety net that's
your fallback and you need that money
available to you i think if you were to
put it in the market
and all of a sudden the market takes a
tank tomorrow it goes down
five percent it keeps keeps going down
for the next few months and now your 12
000 is worth eight i think that would
put you in a really delicate position
that you don't want to be in
the only thing i would do for you right
now because you have six months of your
expenses that's good that's your
emergency fund
so what i would do is take that a year
of my expenses potentially eventually
potentially
but i would just count what you have
right now yeah right right so cool you
have six months worth of your expenses
saved up
in cash uh where is sitting right now
just the bank
what bet like i well actually we don't i
don't even know what bank is it a high
interest savings account my social
security number
yeah what is it a high interest savings
account what is just some normal account
i like i have like a check two checkings
and a savings and i just usually
you can tell us that tell us the bank
and we'll just bleep it out
uh the bank that you're banking with i
have an account with them too
oh oh we also have the the phone call
for you to do
oh so if you want to well we'll get to
that in a second
i i have the same bank as you do and i
use that just for my checking account i
think
this this bank i won't mention it guys
but this bank for checking out is fine
i would not keep with them more than
like two thousand bucks
i keep one month of your expenses with
them open up an account with ally bank
totally free tonight you should do this
they pay one percent
on their savings account so you're gonna
get a totally free bank account there's
no minimums there's no hidden fees
there's nothing
you get one percent in your money
because where you're getting right now
is like nothing you're getting like
0.01 percent so now you could get one
percent
on let's just call it 10 grand you know
so you'll get an extra what is it 100
bucks yeah
what ten dollars a month yeah so
basically you'll get like
because my bank charges me like five
dollar a month fee for each account or
whatever
don't do that no no they're a horrible
bank ally bank that's where i have
like the majority of my money is with
allied bank i like them a lot totally
free do that
okay get in the habit that's your
emergency fund what you could also
i was about to say you could put some
money in a in a penalty free security
applicable to everyone
it is yeah uh you could also part of me
thinks that you could put your money in
a no penalty cd where basically
i would recommend you put like five
grand in there
it's a no penalty cd you're gonna get
just below one percent of interest
but you could take the money out at any
time you get to keep the interest
interest rates might go down so it's
kind of like you're betting i would
probably just say take the one percent
right now open up a high interest
savings account really easy
keep the money in there if you make more
money
then what i'd probably do is just put in
let's say you get to 30. i would
probably take your 12 i beef it up to
16.
that's eight months of your expenses
because your income is going to be like
variable
so just keep no matter what eight months
of your expenses in cash just sitting on
the sidelines
anything over that i would just max out
your roth ira
okay so open up a roth ira with uh you
could do like charles schwab
fidelity vanguard they're all free and
just do vt sacks it's just a broad
index fund i have no clue what that even
is but i just like trust your opinion it
just seems
seems like a good like it's you know
your stuff you got these million
subscriber plaques
it's a safe investment it's it vt sax
is basically it you're betting on the
entire stock market basically so
it's an index fund that covers
everything out there for the most part
so you're betting well not even betting
you're investing with the expectation
that over the long term
the price of that and businesses are
going to be expanding and growing and
making more money and the population is
going to be increasing and
typically historically a fund like that
is made about an eight percent return
oh so that's good over 20 30 years so
some years you're going to lose money
some years you're going to make way more
than that can i take it out whenever i
want
the roth ira is this so the way a roth
ira works
is that you can contribute so basically
you could put up to six thousand dollars
a year into this account
and you could take out what you put in
so if you put in six thousand dollars
you could take it out but once it's out
it becomes very difficult to put that
money back in okay so and you could only
do six thousand dollars a year
the other thing is that let's say your
six thousand dollars grows to sixty five
hundred dollars today of 500 bucks
profit
that profit has to stay in there
otherwise
you pay a 10 penalty and you have to pay
taxes
on that on that profit so my
recommendation would be
whatever money you put in a roth ira
that's your that's your fallback that
that's a bit of your retirement fund so
you just put it in there you don't touch
it you don't look at it
and ideally all you do is six thousand
dollars a year
in the roth ira and vt sacks
and you don't look at it you don't touch
it and then at the age of 59 and a half
all the profit you made within that
account is going to be tax-free
so ideally six thousand dollars a year
over 30 years and an 80
return works out to be i i think it's
about like 800 000 bucks or 900 thousand
dollars over 30 years
uh i think that's correct man you got to
be 60 to get it
you have to be 60. so you could
pull out if you need to your whatever
you contribute so if you're doing 6 000
a year over 10 years you have 60 000 in
there that you could take out at any
time with no penalty but then the
profits you got to wait
still right but the profit you have to
wait otherwise you pay taxes on the
profit and a 10
penalty okay ideally you never take
money out of it before 59 and a half
unless it's a dire emergency unless you
really need the money
and there's no other options either like
i'm being homeless or i take money of
the roth ira then do it
but i think i'm gonna have to re-watch
this part when you post it
yeah because because it's i'll have to
write everything down
i have a video on this it's it's uh just
if you if you
youtube roth ira graham stefan my video
will come up
okay awesome but yeah that's all i would
recommend for you and i think
your most important thing is just
keeping cash on the sidelines
in case something happens in case your
income goes down in case it takes you a
long time to get a job
you have something to fall back on
that's going to last you eight months
great free advice thank you there you go
you're welcome
i have one final question okay because
i've gone through all my questions
would you be willing to include a link
to an
auction if i did auction friend boom in
addition to the link to the book
and would it make sense for me to start
the auction at five thousand dollars
no okay i'll agree to include the link
yeah we'll include the link we'll
include the links so we'll do that
in the book what's up oh never mind i'm
being greedy
you let us know the links you want put
in the description happy to support
whatever
um i would not god i would not recommend
putting
the reserve at 5k here's the thing how
the reserve started there
what's up start the auction at 5k start
at five i
i would how much do you how badly do you
really want to sell it
like is this i'm not gonna do anything
with it otherwise because i got so much
on my plate at the moment and i want it
to exist
so i'll just sell it i'll just sell it
would you sell it for three thousand
sure
what about like two are you thinking
about buying
no no no i'm just saying like
if you want it just if you just want it
to exist you know
maybe just have like a low auction
because you don't even
yeah i'll start at 2 500. okay you could
i would say
i don't want to tell you that but also
would i be taking advantage of someone
if i started it there like
because this is your viewers i'm
advertising it to you it's it's there i
don't want to take advantage depends who
sees value in this
okay yeah if that's all that's all it is
if someone really wants to pursue i mean
my thought is this okay
the idea is already out there yes my
thought is if someone
like you believe in my career is what
we're asking them
because if if you have a guaranteed
brand deal from me
and my career is on the rise
so but really what they're paying for is
your endorsement
and you to make a video it's just that's
really where whatever time they choose
but maybe after five years it expires
and i won't do it if they turn it into
some scam website or something
and then i'll then i'll void the
contract yeah it then it becomes
complicated with contracts
no contract just a just a trust system
or whatever realistically i think
your time is best spent smoothie madness
and that's
that's really like focusing on the
friend boom thing right now even
creating the listing it's just not
like a proper use of your time and i
just don't i'm not confident that it
would pay out but i don't want to like
not encourage you i'm thinking the only
way to do that if you wanted to sell it
is just a
clean break it's just like listen like
two three grand or whatever it might but
whatever someone pays whatever gets
bidded to
two three grand or whatever and you will
do one video on it or something like
that
because otherwise if you just do the
friend system let's just say this this
app blows up
yeah you know it's sell it then google
buys it for a billion dollars you're
like wait a second we had we had a
friend
thing we had a friend agreement was like
no we didn't then it starts getting
weird and then all of a sudden you know
i would do a clean break
be very upfront with the expectation
that like listen i'll do one video on
this
if you want me involved i'm willing to
do it for a set price yeah
but that's my involvement and i i yeah
that's that's a good way to do it and
then for my own sanity say like
you know what like i have other things i
can focus on i hope this gets made i
hope it sells for a billion dollars
eventually
but uh but for now like i'm not going to
pursue that because i'm going to pursue
creativity instead yeah um yeah i think
but this might be ten years from now
they say
look at the moment that he lost himself
a billion dollars
i'll go back to this video and he sold
he sold the idea for 2000
mark zuckerberg buys it how important is
it for you to have a lot of money
oh it's great because then you don't
have to work at an ice cream shop you
don't have to
to do anything and you can just do
creativity and stuff
i guess i don't know it does add more
pressure though i will say the more you
make
the more pressure there is to continue
that moment because then you don't want
to waste it
then it's like oh you build built this
up to be this thing and now it's like
you don't want to throw that away and
you want and you realize too the more
you make
you realize it's like you're in such a
fortunate position that like
why would you want to discontinue
something like that
that's a good point it adds a bit of a
complication to it i think i'm pretty
good at
like i think i'd like if i made like a
million dollars and i said
stick around another year you'll make
another million but it's like oh but
instead i could go do this movie project
i think i would do that movie project
you do the movie project
once i get that certain amount where
it's like oh okay now i can set up
the next part have you thought about how
much that would be for you no but that's
a good question so i'll tell you how to
figure that out
okay how do you like your current
lifestyle now
let's say it's it's great i i wouldn't
change anything i i
think i would like a little bit of a
bigger apartment um
um but actually it's not that important
like
that's not that important at all um so
everything is fine
like money-wise like uh yeah do you want
yeah
i would like to take more trips but
that's not even a factor right now
yeah do you want a family one day do you
want to have like the kids or anything
like that that's
not that i know of like maybe someday i
would but i don't have any goals
like aspirations child wise or whatever
okay
a million bucks i would say probably
less than a million so
so for you to be able to spend two
thousand dollars a month
yeah but indefinitely let's let's even
bump that at the 27.50
a month for you to spend that that's
that's enough right 500 months
so what i would do is 27.50 times 12. so
you're spending 33
000 a year okay what you're going to be
doing is basically
for that money to last you indefinitely
in an index fund portfolio
you could spend about three percent of
that every year without ever running out
so what all you do is you take your
annual spending of 33 000
multiply that by 33 and we got almost
1.1 million bucks
so if you could get yourself to 1.1
million dollars
you could basically guarantee that you
will get 27.50
a month for the rest of your life
without ever running out of money
whoa so that that's how much i have to
make a million dollars to just be set
for like one million dollars
would pretty much give you your current
lifestyle
the reason the reason behind it is that
you're investing in something
whatever you're investing in is growing
yes and then if you withdraw
a little bit of what it's growing each
year it can continue growing
and you could be spending the money that
it's making so it will continue growing
you're never actually you're not
actually decreasing what you have as the
saving or as
from what you're withdrawing from you're
never decreasing that but you're just
taking a little bit of how much it's
growing
this is crazy information to learn yeah
this is how
they don't they don't they don't teach
you this no they don't they don't
i gotta make a million bucks to be set
for life i would say one
so realistically it's 1.1 because it's
it's like a million 89 or something
let's
ground it i'm a million one that's if
you want to live off 27.50 a month which
is more than what you're currently
living off of
oh yeah if you want to do twenty two
thousand dollars a month let's just say
a million
yeah that's a million it's got a nice
ring to it yeah two thousand dollars a
month
twenty four thousand dollars a year
attempting the least you could do is
eight hundred grand
so here's what i'll do i will list that
auction
and see what people come at me with no
yeah i'll do that and i'll say also
email me if if you want an alternate
thing and if someone emails me a better
offer
i'll cancel the auction okay that's good
and like this way it's just open to the
world and uh
also yeah yeah yeah
but now at least you know that's how
much money you really need
and if you could make 2 200 bucks a
month in doubt that you could focus on
whatever you wanted to do
yes and not have to worry about rent
or you know food or anything like that
you keep exactly
but but the problem is if let's say you
want kids
one day or you want a nicer apartment or
something
you know you need a nicer car then all
of a sudden now you need some more money
to pay for it on the back
which maybe as you grow older that's
that stuff will start to like be like
called to me
i've yes i so what i've thought is that
uh generally over time you end up
spending a little bit more money
because you want some more options
usually for a lot of people they're not
going to be happy just with the exact
same thing over and over and over again
they like to see that they're they're
coming up in life that they're
increasing
it doesn't have to be like from from a
shack to a mansion overnight but it
could be
you know you're in 400 square feet you
want to treat yourself down to 450.
you let's do that for a few years you
want something like sisyphus
it's what sisyphus you push a boulder up
a mountain or whatever never heard of
that
oh is that the the guy that's in like
it's like some greek thing
yeah it was just punishment but it's
like you never get there
so you have to just like you're never
gonna get there no no i mean that that's
human psychology it's the um
uh why am i blanking on it what's it
like the adonik treadmill
okay that sounds like very similar
exactly so you're never gonna get there
but like a hamster wheel
it is a hamster wheel because well two
things one rat race
hedonic treadmill so you're always going
to stay at your same baseline no matter
really what happens
but the other thing is that we as people
want to continually progress
so to feel good a lot of people will
need to see
them doing something to moving towards
something and not just staying still
so you have a mix towards feeling the
same way long term
but still needing to progress and do a
little bit more and
and and feel like you know things are
improving in your life
so it's a it's a weird mix between the
two that's a good so that's a great
analog
that's like a great uh yeah just a bit
of advice
yeah so i i just caution you that that
what you're spending now
i think at some point maybe not you
could very well just be like you know
what i want to move to colorado
i i could live in a in a camper i mean
they think
i rent every year also so i will need to
be making more and more so like
naturally i will need to figure things
out but
i'll just look at like friend boom
wealthy influencer as an experiment
uh i'll throw it out there maybe
something amazing will happen
and it's just an experiment so whatever
happens happens
my main passion is gonna be these other
things smoothie madness
i put out this book maybe i'll write
another book i have this podcast thing
that like someone asked me to make a
video for
hopefully that works out and and then
that's where i'll focus my energy
and i'll keep in the back of my mind
this thing you've taught me about
make a million dollars you're pretty
much set for life you will need to make
some adjustments
but pretty much you're set um at least
the baseline
so i'll keep that back there remain open
to
this looks like the next opportunity
that could bring me that and here's the
thing when i made
indoor garden my invention it didn't
work out
but i made a documentary when i made
wealthyinfluencer.com didn't go as
planned still could but
i have that book to show for it what
will come a friend boom
a billion dollar website app or
a documentary or nothing you know it's
just an experiment i'll learn exactly
if you go into things and you say i'm
gonna learn
that's the way to do it i agree and a
million bucks by the way
keep in mind you don't have to be like
what's what's the next idea just like
get it as soon as possible
that could be over 20 years i mean that
could be investing
you know 700 bucks a month yeah i would
like it as soon as possible but everyone
would like that
it's true but how do you make the world
a place where everything is automated
and no one has to work uh we should we
could ask andrew yang
universal basic income which we're
getting
i don't know anything about universal
basic income or whatever but that would
be the
cool no like i mean some people like
doing waiter jobs and stuff
but i would prefer not to and i bet a
lot of other people would so that's what
we gotta figure out
but in the meantime you can make things
like friend boom
wealthy influencer
keep going yeah whatever i like that you
made good use of the time while you're
at home
and you're working towards something i
think that's a lot more valuable than
doing nothing or just
just sitting around moping around being
bored
you have something to show for it that's
true but also if you're at home
and you didn't do that it's okay right
like like not
everyone knows what to do right away
because there's definitely been times
where i
didn't know what to do with my time and
didn't do anything productive
so someday if you want to write books
you'll be doing it too
yeah are you making money on youtube
right now oh well i usually make like
50 to 100 a month this month uh
like a thousand because that documentary
came out
and uh that's only the first few day
like the
like most of that's from the past week
you need to post more on youtube
yeah if you can have a schedule you
could actually be making a decent amount
just from that
you need to i mean i don't see any
reason why you couldn't be that is a
good point
the only thing is i don't have enough
ideas to do it regularly
and so i like whenever i put something
out for it to be exciting and impactful
and people notice like oh it's a new
book
because if i just posted a vl but i
actually am filming a vlog that's why i
filmed you when i first got here
yeah because i want to make a 20 minute
vlog that's called july vlog
just because it was such an interesting
month for me so that will be an
experiment and maybe i will start
posting more
maybe i'll start having more ideas i'll
tell you i have the ideas here
your next big video i think you can get
50 to 100
000 views on this is responding to the
comments
of your video of ice cream man i'll
incorporate that into the next smoothie
madness
i would now i think that's a good
standalone video okay
answering answering comments or you just
title the video
answering the haters responding to the
haters
seriously that's it because people love
that what if i made one called this
one's for the haters
no just responders all lower caps
lower caps yeah yeah all lowercase
just responding to the haters period at
the end
you could do it to the jubilee video as
well what you you should uh
also react to the jubilee video as well
okay yeah a couple reaction videos yeah
maybe give a little bit more of an
explanation on why you chose blue
and uh yeah reacting to the comments and
stuff yeah i like get responding to
haters would be one video
the next video uh talking about smoothie
madness and my response would be this
don't listen to the haters it would be
it was good
we need a long we need to get it to 10
minutes though so we put mid-roll ads in
the videos
so what i would do is go through all the
comments you could read the nice ones
but if anything is is bad respond to it
and just and just you could that's going
to destroy me
would it yeah don't do it okay yeah
if you're able to take an approach to it
like it's comedy
and you're able to look at this
objectively and think like this is a
stupid comment let's roast them let's
make fun of it
and you turn it into a lighthearted
video then maybe i can respond to hate
with positivity and i use it to teach a
lesson
but i i'm better at teaching lessons in
books and stuff but i can write it out
beforehand maybe yeah
i think it's also important though that
you know yourself and if you think
that if you will see comments like that
and they will ruin your day they linger
then don't do it okay okay don't do it
then okay this is because yeah for me
when when i first started reading those
those negative comments for me
destroyed me i mean they would ruin my
entire day
now now i am at the point it doesn't
really matter no negative comments on
this video
we got such a support there no one's
gonna say anything negative but um
other otherwise we will dislike your
comment or constructive criticism
welcome but that's just my message to
everyone like let's be more positive
okay
then don't do the responding to haters
because because i think because yeah
you know yourself if you're gonna get to
the point where it's i could do it for
the clicks but probably should
put it aside and just focus on smoothie
maps movie madness
yeah smoothie madness is a it's the way
to go yeah
i agree i like smoothie madness so
let just quickly let's talk about your
your features
in in like mainstream films are you
still collecting royalties
from those yeah uh i i i get checks for
like 200 or 300 bucks like
every few months from those but at one
point i got like a check for like twelve
thousand dollars
that was that was like in 2013 or
something and i didn't even know it was
coming
so that was amazing and so that's why
well
i don't want to sound like i only care
about the money but that's one of the
reasons why
i need to get more acting work because
it pays so well it's just so hard to get
but but i also just love doing acting
but now i've found other outlets for my
creativity
we've got documentaries books smoothie
madness
and even business stuff like when i was
creating wealthyinfluencer.com
i was so like inspired and like it was
because i was realizing this vision i
wanted to create a website
that was simple and easy to use and was
it very intuitive
decently so yeah a little and did you
look at the courses at all
yeah we watched we watched some of the
videos cool it was a little
like where to go next i was expecting a
buy it now button well here's the th
what like a buy it now like like
something with something i had to
purchase
oh no nothing is for sale it's all free
yeah it's a free like free to use
website
but it doesn't have a tool section
developed yet once it has those then it
would be like something i would return
to and keep using
and i really love the community uh
someone tried to impersonate me on there
so i do not use the community on there
if you ever see someone posting as me
it's not me can you
just delete them yeah i deleted it but
okay i don't want to look at it that
often so got it
if you see it in the future it's not me
but also
i don't know how i got there but yeah
yeah
are you able to share how much you made
from your
movie appearances yeah uh like
thirty or forty thousand dollars i just
talked about it on the h3 podcast
last week so you made 30 or 40 000
from project x and 21 jump street mm-hmm
how did you get those roles what was it
what was it like did you did you know
somebody or you just responded to an ad
it was an open casting call but i had a
manager so i had this one manager
ditched him well he ditched me he fired
me or stopped working with me
got this other manager he told me about
this open casting call
project x flew me out they cast me
easy first audition so lucky
second audition i almost got but i
didn't third audition 21 jump street
got it so lucky
um luck is a big part of success y'all
are both successful do you agree
it's not everything but it's a vital
thing
ian didn't have to make that documentary
about me
if he had not made it i would probably
not be here
learning about how i need to make a
million bucks learning all this great
advice
i might be on unemployment
uh who knows i maybe maybe i would be in
a movie who knows
you never know but there is an element
to that though where you had a lot of
work that went in
leading up to that yes it is not the
only thing that leads to success but it
is one of the vital ingredients
so what was the question
uh that's a good question what is the
question yeah what is the question
i just i just asked how much uh how much
you you had made
oh and then i was asking about the
audition process yeah so
you got so lucky getting into these
movies and then it didn't pan out
afterwards
uh i didn't get into as many movies
afterwards which is fine
i'm not saying it's cause of bad luck
that wasn't my point but
i got really close to being in this ryan
gosling movie
and i got really close to being in this
we are the millers
um yeah didn't it but but you know i'm
happy with where i am now
we'll see what happens next is there
anything you would have changed
are there any regrets no i'm looking
back and you're just like i don't think
done that i don't think of that
okay it's probably helpful in some ways
but mostly it's not helpful
sometimes i think for me i'll look back
at things i wish i could have changed or
done differently
and then just internalized that and
thought to myself okay well at least i
could
use that as a learning experience and
make sure you know in the future if that
situation comes up or
that opportunity presents itself now i
know perfectly i look
at it kind of how i see it yeah that's
great advice
when you first started out on youtube
who are some of the most prolific
creators
smosh lisa nova
yeah hmm
i don't really like to think about the
old days too much
oh anyways okay what do you
what what interests you what do you like
talking about
big ideas what's next or even small
things i like to talk about
nature walks hikes
what would be your favorite activity to
do if you could pick anything that you
could do
going for a long walk okay oh and
creativity how long
two hours quarantine has given me a lot
of time to go for walks it's been really
good for that and i'm lucky that i have
the unemployment coming in yeah well i
don't i don't think i will anymore now
that i have other money coming in i'll
have to report it and cancel the
price but that's okay because it'll come
it'll be more than unemployment would
have been where do you like to walk to
everywhere i love discovering new places
like
places i haven't ever walked before
through quarantine i've discovered so
many nooks and crannies in my
neighborhood
it's it's odd but now i feel like going
on a walk like that
yeah i know like you talking about your
excitement
makes me be like there's so many places
like i would love
and i haven't been able to do it so much
this week that's why i think that
i couldn't sleep because i've like
instead i've had all these ideas going
and uh which is exciting but you got to
balance it out
gosh i want to go on a long walk just
like nothing impatient just just walk
we can do that tonight if you'd like if
you want to go alone
no no i'm good i've got to cook dinner
tonight would you consider yourself more
introverted or extroverted
uh introverted that's why i like walks
do you think would you would you like a
walking partner like someone to walk
with or you guys could walk
that's good but i like both okay i like
both but yeah
if you had friendboom.com you could go
on what do i want to do go for a hike
with someone
and you go for a hike with someone who
has a nice compatible person you do if
you didn't like the person after 20
minutes like you start on the walk
there should be like an ejector button
no no you got to be nice still
because uh then you just you just have
to use your social skills
so you would just can you get ratings
like can you can they have like a public
rating
not a public one but you can report on
your experience so friend boom can
improve its algorithm
um so if someone has a whole bunch of
negatives like they stop
they stop recommending yeah they stop
pushing the shadow band the person
that way the algorithm could like
navigate like how to adjust itself so
that it like
knows to like okay we didn't succeed
this time let's do it better next time
and then if a person cancels the hangout
yeah and doesn't report it
they get suspended from the platform i
would agree imagine putting too low
ratings
yeah that's what they would do they put
the lows together it wouldn't be a it
wouldn't be a five star system
also i think your battery's low um oh
friend boom would adjust its algorithm
and you wouldn't give ratings on a five
star actually i shouldn't talk about it
anymore i'll seem like i'm just going on
and on
i don't want it to be too pitchy or
anything it's not pitchy but yeah okay
cool so it would be a fi
it wouldn't be a five star system it
would be more were you compatible or not
what would you look for instead so it's
not writing a person
numerically it's rating the algorithms
match
abilities and the algorithm learns from
that
ideally it doesn't exist yet so i'll
probably do the same thing i think if i
were matched with a friend to go on a
walk and after 20 minutes it's just like
i'm just bored out of my i'd probably do
the walk
finish it off and then afterwards it's
that's an awkward
then it's awkward at that point like hey
man i don't know if we can go on another
walk after
unless it was terrible unless it was
like all really really really bad you're
looking at the worst case scenario
yeah i mean i don't know if that would
ever happen yeah just ghost them like
the messaging should be on the
okay look that's why you can't launch
this until the personality rating system
has been thoroughly
vetted yeah that would be interesting
yeah very sophisticated personality
rating system
or personality not rating uh
personality test no yeah it's almost
like you're making a dating app
just for friendship yeah yeah but but
also with games involved and stuff so
and do you want to hear about the
business model or should we wrap things
up
i let's hear about the business model
free media so so it's free to use for
the most part but if you want to like
unlock certain games
then you pay to use those games or if
you want to match with like up to
if you've already done like used five
matches like in a week and you've like
already done five hangouts
then you have to pay for your sixth
seventh etc like so everything after
five you pay for
you pay for the games and stuff and then
uh
additionally you gamify the whole thing
so people want to keep using it
so you can somehow have leaderboards and
stuff i don't know how you would do that
but maybe there's some way to gamify it
most hangouts
yeah or i mean that might not that's not
like the most people you've hung out
with yeah and you call it the most
i don't think that should be i don't
think it should be like
you should be a contest of who can hang
out with most people because that's like
they're wrong man we gotta wrap this up
i have another hangout
coming over oh oh okay um yes so
so so but yeah um
yeah like some other way to gamify it
yeah that's that's
interesting i'm thinking like five
people is a lot
like five people to hang out five people
in a week yeah yeah you should do
everything after three
hangouts yeah you pay for something like
that
advertising is where i think a good
amount yeah advertising will play
advertising
here's where i think um like waze could
make a lot of money
is uh like you know you you pick your
destination
and they would give you businesses along
the way that'll offer you this oh yes
this is perfect so you team up with yelp
and you say hey
you want to go to a restaurant they want
to go to a restaurant are you open to
vegan
then it lists a restaurant what's on
yelp
yeah so you partner uh with these things
and you you do it also
if it's not yelp whatever rating place
you do for star and above only so you
know that you're not just
sending people to some bad place it's
been thoroughly vetted
yeah yeah i agree i think that would be
that would be it
it's tough to then make like individual
deals all these like
little restaurants you know it becomes
complicated then
but making an iphone is complicated
that's true
but that's also a like a well i don't
even know 10
000 person man production like it's out
of the work right but not when it was
just an idea it wasn't
yeah steve jobs so i'm
i'm saying this not to say i'm the next
steve jobs but
if someone is hearing this idea and
wants to make it
don't be scared of the complications it
can happen
exactly and that goes for any other
venture
you are thinking of embarking on i'm not
just saying that
to get people to buy my site saying it
to inspire people to do whatever you
want to do
and also this site might not even sell i
hope i haven't been too pitchy
you have not been pitchy because yeah
i'm really excited about these other
things too
see we could tell there's a difference
between trying to pitch something i
don't even feel tired anymore
and uh yeah exactly and uh being excited
about something like that
okay yes good point good point so
totally different i think people can
pick up on that
and when you're pitchy people like if i
kept asking you to invest in it then it
would feel weird
yes yeah but no it's totally fine do you
have any questions for grammar i
oh i already asked them i already asked
all the questions is there any other
thing
any anything else you're confused about
or anything else you want to know
no no i'm just going to rewatch this
video later i'll ask
i'll seek out the time stamp where uh
you talk about
roth iras and stuff and try and absorb
that information better
uh okay because yeah that's perfect
if if only everyone had this opportunity
to have
life recorded because then you don't
have to worry about forgetting things
yep
part of me wishes you could always just
have like a like a body cam that's
turned out this is as long as a whole
movie
yeah i would love that though like i i
wish at some point like there's a little
like yeah like like a contact you could
put in your eye
that's always recording like everything
and it's being uploaded to a cloud
and it picks up audio perfectly too but
someday that will exist
yeah i would love that and then if if
you forget something or you're curious
you just you could pick the day and the
time and you could go back and re-watch
from your perspective what's going on
i kind of always thought that would be
what it would be like after you like
pass away
the reason i don't try and create that
is because
i'm not passionate about that that's why
i'm creating these other things because
i'm a little more qualified
but you're saying that's what you think
it's going to be like when you die
that's interesting i
i think it's it's a it's a good
perspective because then it makes you
think that
you should make the most out of your
current life so when you do pass away
you can
go back and enjoy the fruits that here
is here's maybe my theory so i have a
few theories on this video it's like a
big movie theater after you die and you
just watch the whole thing
no no you'd probably be able to
like assume the you're like the movie
click
like fast kind of will you be like
in your body like you can like you can
send yourself
to to be yourself in that specific time
like it's not like you're watching
certain moments you relive certain
moments yes
i'll tell you what i what i think i've
got so many theories about this
part of me believes there's a chance
that you just keep reliving your life
over and over and over again like the
moment you you you die
you just show up again you're born again
and
but you have i guess a little bit more
wisdom or you have some like sometimes
people have intuitions about certain
things or they have
they have these strong feelings towards
or against something
sometimes people have like like fears
about something that are irrational but
they're really you know so i think maybe
we we go in
to each life with just a little bit more
wisdom and can better improve ourselves
through that i've also thought what
happens if
every single time you come back as
somebody else
but then you get that makes more sense
but then you get into the perspective of
well
how many thousands of millions of years
has life existed for what if you come
back as every single life form like one
time you might come back is like the ant
that's outside
then another time you like come back as
the aunt that's like 300 years old
uh one life i come back is you know you
my mom let's just say
and you could relive that was a weird
one but but you would remember that you
were graham
what's up you would remember that you're
graham no because that wouldn't make
sense
i think you'd remember your no you
wouldn't you wouldn't remember a single
thing but you just get to live
the life of someone you don't believe in
karma or you do
i i do i do when i
don't i mean i believe what goes around
comes around i really believe that
if you are a negative person if you're
mean
you will generally attract more of that
and and life has a funny way of
of getting what you put out so i believe
if you're a bad person
if you screw people over you will find a
way to put yourself in positions where
you will you will experience that too
yeah what do you think
i don't know yeah i don't know i like to
think that
when i when i'm upset or really upset it
often comes down to
me feeling bad for myself so something
unfortunate will happen and i'll sit
there and be like oh my gosh i can't
believe this happened and i'll start
ruminating and thinking about it over
and over again
and it it makes it worse but if i can
twist a bad event into some sort of like
learning event
or i can think well this only happens
every once in a while or i can try to
have a more positive spin on it
it makes it better for me oh here's a
great story we could end on this
i'm gonna butcher this story terribly
but it goes perfectly for exactly what
you're saying
uh there was this old story that went
out there that was about
a guy who lived on a farm and his horses
ran away
and the neighbor said wow your horses
ran away that was really bad luck
and the guy said we'll see the horses
came back a week later but brought back
more horses with it and the neighbor
said wow
that was really good luck and he says
we'll see
then his son is on is working on the
farm and breaks his leg and the neighbor
said wow that's really bad luck
and the guy said we'll see and they came
in
the army came in shortly after that to
draft people for the war
and the son's leg was broken and so he
wasn't drafted and the neighbor said wow
that was really lucky and the guy said
we'll see
and so it really just depends on your
perspective on things and even though a
bad event might happen now
you never know how that will turn itself
around into a really fortunate event in
the future like exactly
sometimes the yeah thank you thank you i
thought that was poetic
hit the like button for that one but but
seriously though when you when you look
at really
bad events it might not seem like it now
but you will never know in like 20 30
years even
at the end of your life you look back at
that and and something has changed or
something someone came up to you and
just like killed you
that would be very you would say that
would be very unlucky
yeah and then hope that you get
reincarnated right see the thing about
that is
for the people that you died
yeah so the people who are left are
super sad
so maybe them they learned that lesson
you were just embarked
uh
there is like there's something missing
in you and you can't really live a fully
fulfilling life after that or you just
you don't get to enjoy
my own my point is more like usually
everything has a silver lining
i guess i was playing devil's advocate
that's true but in a way that was like
i don't know why i said that because
you're making a very positive point
but it just popped into my it's a good
and the other thing that popped into my
mind is like just put a
like this is more missing the point but
like yeah
why doesn't he just capture the horse
like why doesn't he put up a fence or
whatever
and like so but like sure but like
anyways there's all these ways
the sun should have been more careful
you can miss the point a lot yes
like a lot of the time so i
i am getting you off track and you were
trying to wrap it up so
i love where it's gone no because it's
it is true
i think then it then it becomes a game
of mental gymnastics of trying to figure
out how it fits a narrative that's
what's philosophical
is that what philosophy is now a little
bit yeah i mean like essentially
not everything but essentially if
someone ended me right now
i'd pretend jack wouldn't jump in front
of a bullet
but um but let's say that i would hope
that that would that would cause some
sort of
like like some sort of movement or at
least bring awareness to something
like like honestly if anything happens i
think uh like that's what i meant
is like if if you die like if i died
then like still
uh something can come out for the people
who are still alive i would
like heartbroken like if you go through
loss or something still something good
can come out eventually i would like to
see some sort of long-term
change in a positive direction at least
that's what i would like to see
uh then it would make it would it make
it worse conservation ocean conservation
would it make it worth it
is that a cause you'd pass away for not
now
i mean let's have that out when i'm 80.
are there causes that you would pass
away for right now
oh man now this is
um so yeah let's wrap it up yeah that's
just about it is there anything else you
want to say
uh please buy my book please tell me
what you think about friend why is that
funny
because you said you didn't want to be
pitched you like please by myself oh
well
if you want me to we'll leave it at the
end
please buy my book uh please tell me
what you think about friend boom
um uh please tell me what you think of
wealthy influencer
subscribe to my channel um pass this
video on to your friends subscribe to
graham and
jack thanks for watching
thank you so much for coming on here dax
thanks for having me it's been awesome
meeting you in person although i have
not been able to see you
this entire podcast me and jack can't
see each other so if i like look up into
the distance
while we're conversing that's why
there's a light box with a towel over it
to be like to act as a light diffuser
and it's just you want me to turn this
camera to show
no you're good turn around
can you can you uh if you want to hire
me as a filmmaker all right
can you zoom in on us yeah
there we go so with that said you guys
thank you so much for watching we really
appreciate it make sure to like
subscribe i'm gonna link to
all of dax's information down below in
the description
where you can also get by the way dax
you need to get your two free stocks
down below in the description
get in the get in the frame oh do you
want to be worried about growing okay
okay
yeah so you can get your two free stocks
down below in the description when you
deposit 100
on weeble one of the stocks could
potentially be worth all the way up to
how much
jack fourteen hundred dollars whoa have
you gotten your two free stocks yet
this sounds really pitchy you can get
your two free stocks
i'm passionate about it though i get
excited about weevils two free stocks
you can get your two you seriously
should get two free it's it's free i'll
do it yeah i trust your money except for
sure yeah so all you do
now now it sounds pitchy but no
seriously all you do use the link in the
description
seriously use the link in the
description uh deposit a hundred dollars
on weeble when you open an account
what you what they're gonna do is after
about seven days or so they're gonna
give you two free stocks to open
one of those stocks is going to be worth
anywhere from like three bucks to twelve
dollars
the next one is going to be worth
anywhere from about eight dollars to
fourteen hundred dollars
so you deposit a hundred the least
you're gonna make from that is maybe
like
12 bucks the very most you can make is
like 1400. so
for a hundred dollar investment you'll
make some money back and you could just
withdraw the money at any time so if you
decide afterwards you just want the
money
you could just take the money out but
you have to wait i think like a week or
two
but anyway that that's my pitch like
subscribe
oh how are we gonna do thumbnail
all right we're good yeah cool uh
what's the plan now oh should we do the
intro uh yeah we could do the intro
i don't know if we need an intro
you introduced me already yeah yeah we
introduced you but we usually have like
a welcome back
okay let's just do it really quick one
second yeah